Estados Unidos Apuesta por el futuro de
África
el líder de la Casa Blanca anunció 15
mil millones de dólares en acuerdos
comerciales con los líderes africanos
parte de lo cual se destinará a la
energía limpia un contraste implícito
con china a menudo criticado por
financiar centrales eléctricas de carbón
en África y alrededor del mundo Joe
biden destacó que la revolución digital
La infraestructura y el empleo bien
remunerado son fundamentales para el
desarrollo del continente y Estados
Unidos está alistando sus inversiones
para este propósito sin hacer mención
específica de la participación china en
el Continente vaiden tuvo cuidado de
diferenciar los motivos estadounidenses
de los chinos
asociaciones no para crear una
obligación política para fomentar la
dependencia sino para estimular el éxito
compartido enfatizaría el éxito
compartido y la oportunidad pero sus
anuncios están lejos de ser
desinteresados la creciente influencia
de Rusia y china en suelo africano una
competencia para Washington
estamos siendo testigos de que la
República popular china amplía su huella
en el Continente a diario y mientras
hacen eso también están expandiendo su
influencia económica
Al hacer que la ayuda a la
infraestructura esté condicionada
estándares democráticos la Casa Blanca
Se presenta como menos oportunista que
sus rivales y enfatiza la importancia de
la salud pública y la gobernanza trans